hi everyone welcome to today's
homeroom live stream uh today we will do
an
ask me anything which is always fun i
enjoy it a lot
before we dive into the questions
although i encourage you to start
thinking of questions and putting them
in the message boards on facebook or
youtube or wherever you're you're
watching this
we have team members will help surface
these to me but literally ask anything
and i'm also asking team members
surface whatever shows up even some of
the more
uh less traditional questions but before
we break into it i will give my standard
announcement reminding folks that khan
academy is a not-for-profit organization
that means that
no one owns khan academy i don't own
khan academy or you own as much of khan
academy as i do and we can only exist
because of philanthropic donations from
folks like yourself so if you're in a
position to do so
please think about donating i also want
to give special thanks to several
organizations that have supported khan
academy
pre-covered but especially when they saw
that we were running at a deficit going
into the crisis and our costs were going
up because of server costs and new
programs and courses we wanted to create
special thanks to bank of america
google.org att fastly and novartis
who've helped us close the gap although
we're still running at a deficit
and donations of all sizes make a
difference so if you're in a position to
do so
please think about making a donation to
khan academy
so with that i am eager to take your
questions
about literally anything
and uh yeah ask
ask me about anything and i i don't have
the questions in yet so i'll just start
talking about random stuff i was
looking at that little uh starting
screen for the live stream and it
reminded me
about how bad my current haircut is not
that my previous haircut was good but
several people have asked in the past
about this this haircut was done with a
clipper
in about 80 seconds the spacex launch
was about to happen
i didn't want to miss it i was in my
backyard so i took the clipper from my
wife who was
a more accomplished uh a barber than i
am
that's not what she does by training
she's a rheumatologist but that's how i
got this haircut
um i know none of you have asked about
that but i do feel self-conscious about
that
so let's see from youtube elliott h says
what do you think about lack of privacy
on the internet we saw abuse of power in
george floyd's murder
do you worry that data collected by ggl
i guess google
and facebook will be used to hurt people
someday
wow that's a that's a very big question
elliot
i don't know um and you know regardless
of
what your point of view is on data
privacy you know kind of the genie might
be out of the bottle regardless you know
we have a world now where everyone's got
cell phones
everyone can do live streams everyone
can record something and put it
immediately on the internet
now for the most part we see you know
we're seeing
examples of that being used for good
we're seeing examples of that
being able to document things that we've
heard about but
when you see it you just realize how
horrific it could be like george floyd's
murder
or what happened with the bird watcher
in central park and
and those are just two of the more
recent examples this is happening almost
on a daily basis now
and that is creating more transparency
more accountability
um and and you know that'll probably
drive better behavior because
you know in the past uh people who
wanted to get away with something would
say well you know no one's gonna notice
but now
it might be someone with a cell phone
who's able to document it it might be a
security camera
you know that's on the the light post
that's able to document it and so you're
you know you're a little bit more more
conscientious about
uh what what might get seen or not seen
so that element
seems good but then of course there's
another side to it which is you know
the the argument there's always been
this tension between
security and observation and then
privacy and
liberty um because you could imagine an
orwellian government one day you know
using that to control
you know who interacts with whom or what
information you know
your track your your your where you move
and and and all of that
uh and and that could be a very scary
thing
um and and there's also
you know not even talking about an
orwellian state there's there's worlds
where you know you're a young person
you're in high school you're in college
you know i've heard young people
sometimes don't do the most you know
high judgment activities you know i
might have been guilty of some of that
myself and
it's not helpful if it's you know you're
doing something kind of silly
you know dancing with your friends in a
silly way or you know
me and and it gets documented and uh
you know shows up on social media and
then you lose all control of it and then
you've lost your privacy and your
ability to kind of just
you know even if it's something fairly
harmless but if an employer sees you
dancing in that really silly way that
might you know
that that might not be a good thing so
yeah it's
it's it's it's a tough tough situation i
think
you know as individual citizens um
you know all i can do is all you young
people out there be careful
with what uh you know of of
of folks recording you uh you know be
careful of your privacy
you you might you know want to post a
bunch of stuff because it'll kind of
make your friends giggle
and and this and that but it could have
very far uh reaching consequences
you know there's definitely examples of
adults
with a lot you know with careers big
careers
who've made some stupid tweets or social
media posts
now for society it might have been good
because then we realized what was really
going on in their mind and we realized
that
they probably don't want them to be the
people entertaining us or the people
uh who have that power but you can
imagine
you know maybe for some of these people
they said wow i made that really dumb
tweet
and now it ruined my career and i think
you know that's something for everyone
to be a little bit thoughtful about
because it can get so easy to
to just kind of be you know unfiltered
in those types of settings so anyway
i i don't know it's it's it's a hard
thing that we're all going to struggle
with together but i said i get a sense
that the genie is already out of the
bottle
everyone's got phones everyone's got
recording devices they can post it onto
social media
i'm even afraid of you know this whole
world of deep fakes
that is becoming more and more possible
where you know you literally could
construct a video
um of someone even if they weren't in
the video which is uh
you know it's cool because you get to
see princess leia in the new star wars
but it can be
um scary in a lot of other things
so let's see from youtube orchid
blossom i like that name why do schools
seem more like memorization testing than
learning fun and useful things
that's a good question orchid so i think
there's two aspects about it there's the
aspect that you control which is
your mindset that you take towards
school and then there's the thing that i
guess
all of us collectively can control but
it's more of a systems change thing
which is
how does school itself present
information
or guide you through that information so
i'll start on what you
yourself can focus on i found that
even if you are in a curriculum that is
very focused on memorization
or you know what seems like random steps
of process
you know it seems like you know how do
you solve this equation and it's not
going to the intuition
there is always some underlying
intuition and
what i would encourage you and i said
this before in the live stream is
remember like
this material even though it might seem
like it's being delivered to you in a
very dry
or disjointed or memorization way
it usually is saying something very
profound about the universe
and even if it's fact knowledge that
fact knowledge is usually quite
useful and so what i would say is you
know remind yourself
that it might not be it might not taste
so good right now but it's telling you
something deep about the universe ponder
it
even if the curriculum you're in isn't
drawing the connections ponder it
take some time indulge think about how
that thing
connects to other things uh in the
universe and
you know that's definitely the attitude
that i took growing up and i did just
because i don't know maybe that's just
how i
thought about things and you know for
sure i used to sit in some classrooms
that felt a little bit wrote
uh felt a little bit not the most
engaging and then i had
other classrooms that were incredibly
engaging and um you know the teacher
really drew the connections and inspired
us and made us appreciate you know how
beautiful what was being
learned really is uh but but when you
have that attitude that regardless of
which classroom you're in you're always
going to ponder it draw connections try
to work through it yourself
uh then it'll all be interesting and it
won't feel like memorization you will
actually retain
much much more of that material now on
the other side what can the system do
different this is where we at khan
academy we are trying our best
and obviously we are far from perfect
there is a curriculum out there
there are standards out there and you
know smart people can have a hearty
debate about what should be in and what
should be out
but i think what we try to do at khan
academy is to try to
present it to you in a way that one you
can get as much practice
and feedback and confidence in the
material as possible but also have fun
doing it and it could be fun because of
the game mechanics and what's known as
extrinsic motivators that have nothing
to do with the content but that's just
motivating to do it
but hopefully it's also fun in the work
itself hopefully
when you're doing the exercise on khan
academy you're like oh i'm kind of
enjoying this
and many of you all have watched videos
on khan academy you'll see i usually am
having fun
uh working through the material and
hopefully that is infectious to you and
hopefully when you see the videos
and and you know if it's me or one of
our other content team creators making
it you see
we're modeling for you that this really
is interesting this really is intuitive
uh this really is telling you something
profound about the universe or
introducing you to a new way of thinking
um so we're gonna try to do our best i
think many educators are also very aware
of what you're alluding to and so i i've
seen
educators more and more doing their best
to really bring the intuition
the interactivity um the human side the
interesting side
because the subjects inherently are
interesting you almost have to work to
make them boring
uh so so hopefully that happens over the
you know over over time and and you see
more and more experiences that are more
engaging and less
you know rote memorization or boring
let's see this is from uh from youtube
fuzzy space
i like that username as well hi sal i
teach
math and one of the things i am
struggling to do is write digital
exercises
for students that assesses proofs
have you guys at khan academy come up
with any ideas on how to do this
fuzzy space you are asking a very big
question that
we at khan academy have struggled with
for many many years and we've tried to
do our best
you know for for those watching who
don't know what a math proof is some of
you might
remember those kind of two column proofs
in geometry and when you took it it
might have seemed like some random
things to the previous question
but a proof at its essence is
can you start with some basic
assumptions about the universe which
we call our axioms things we just assume
and that from
those axes you know one of the axioms is
i exist i just assume i exist
you know it's kind of hard to prove or
disprove you know i think therefore i am
whatever
but it's an axiom that i exist but from
from basic axioms can you
can you build can you deduce other
truths
about the universe assuming that those
axioms are true and that's really one of
the powers
of real mathematics you know abraham
lincoln famously
intimately learned all of euclid's
elements which is what modern geometry
is based on and even though it's you
know we're talking about something
that's 2000 years old
because he realized it made him a much
more rigorous thinker and made him a
better lawyer and made him a better
debater
and so that's what proof is all about
just you know for those of you all who
aren't
you know mathy uh so to speak what's
hard about bruce is
it's inherently a creative process you
know whenever people say like
oh well you can do math this way but you
know creative subjects you have to do
that way and i'll say well no math is
very creative as well you know if you
talk to any mathematician they're coming
up with new and novel proofs
that no one has ever thought about new
ways of deducing
some truth about the universe and
ideally we could build that skill in as
many students as possible even if they
don't become mathematicians they like
abraham lincoln
it will improve their critical thinking
skills and their ability to think
rigorously about what is
for sure true what might be true but is
not proven and what is for sure
not true or what might not be true but
we haven't proven it but we haven't
proven it yet
uh the hard thing about it anything like
that is it's you know in a multiple
choice or in a free response type of
format
uh we at khan academy which is you know
it's hard to make that
auto-gradable or provide auto feedback
we do
attempt to do this in many of the
standards by you know we'll have an
exercise where
there's a proof with multiple steps and
the
the user has to pick whether the proof
is correct and if it isn't correct what
step
was the logical fallacy made in so i
think that's one
area you know we have a couple of things
where you can drag and drop rationales
especially in geometry for why you know
a particular statement could be right
and then what could be the next
statement after that
but to your point it's very very very
hard i think you know the ideal is it
would be similar to what you do in uh
in writing i mean there's there are some
ais that can grade writing now in fact
we use it with our sat work
uh maybe you can do something like that
with proofs i've heard of some projects
i i'm not intimately aware of any of
them
i also think there could be something
around peer review that does it where
imagine you're asked to you know prove
some some
some statement in mathematics and
someone who's already proven it and has
been validated that has proven it maybe
it's an older student or maybe it's just
another student in the classroom
can then look at your proof and and
grade and give you feedback as to
whether it is correct or not
that's an interesting mechanism that
could happen inside the classroom
i'm also intrigued about ways that we
could do that you know in the broader
world um
in the broader world as well so
the from facebook guillermo acosta says
how do we know your child is ready to
begin on khan academy
great question sorry i'm having some
internal i don't know burps i guess
uh so how do you how do you know if your
child is ready for khan academy
so i think there's two major experience
experiences one is khan academy kids and
then
there is you know kind of our our
website which it also has an app
and is available on mobile so khan
academy kids is designed for ages
two to seven it is it covers
all of the head start and common core
standards
for pre-k kindergarten and first grade
in math
reading writing and social emotional
learning and so
if you have someone some especially
between ages 2
and 6 who is kind of at their
developmental level
i highly recommend khan academy kids
it's highly interactive it's tablet or
phone based
so you know kids don't have to know how
to use a mouse or a keyboard or you know
read directions and all of that
i would say our our i guess you know
core khan academy or big khan academy
whatever you want to call about it
i think for third grade and up it is
very
usable um and why the reason why i say
third grade is because khan academy
does presuppose you know if you're using
it online
on the web it presumes some use of the
mouse and the keyboard
and even if you're using it on a mobile
device even if you're using the app it
does require
you know some you know enter the
equation
or you know it says stuff like select
all that apply and
you know to a to a kindergartner select
all apply they might not even be able to
read that so
or even a first grader so um i say third
grade for sure
is where we've seen a lot of and you
know there's definitely examples of
fairly precocious
kindergartners and first graders and
second graders who are have high reading
capability
who are also able to gauge on kind of
big khan academy so to speak starting
with our early learning
work because our content goes all the
way into early learning i would say if
you
have a student a child that's kind of
right at the cusp you know
khan academy kids the first grade
content is feeling a little bit
too easy for them so they're ready to
start going into second and third grade
content on
big khan academy so to speak i would
recommend
for you as a parent or a loved one or
sibling to be able to sit down with that
student
and don't give them the answers don't
tell them how to solve it but explain to
them when it says select all that apply
or if they're having trouble moving
something with a mouse or their motor
skills aren't where they need to be that
you can help them there
and just also motivate them because the
game mechanics or the motivational
mechanics on the
big khan academy are not you know 100
percent designed for the six or year old
or the
the six or seven year old crowd so i
think having a loved one
next to the child working through it i
think that's great for khan academy kids
as well but it's especially important
for the younger students
on um kind of our our non-khan academy
kids
khan academy we have to come up with a
better word for you know big khan
academy i guess
um see facebook kieran dadlani says
would love to know sal's thoughts on how
to get more girls interested in stem
subjects
especially math it's a great question
kieran
i'm not you know i won't claim that i'm
the expert here but
you know i i have anecdotal experience
many of y'all know that khan academy
started with me tutoring
my at the time 12 year old cousin nadia
and
in a lot of ways what she was going
through was
what i think a lot of girls go through
you know she was 12 years old she was a
good student
she was trying to do what's right but
she had kind of convinced herself that
she wasn't a math person
and i don't know where it came from i'm
guessing it probably got
from you know you hear you'll hear your
mother
say that you're not into math or um you
know people gravitate towards
you know i don't know they see a movie
where they disproportionately see that
you know the
the the man's the math guy and the the
the woman's the humanities person and so
they they build these
these internal biases on who they are
and they start to find and i do think
it's around
11 or 12 or 13 year olds uh that that
all of us start really defining like who
we are
you know are what are we quote good at
not good at and obviously that's not a
good attitude to have because that's not
a growth mindset you should say i'm good
i can be good at anything
and i can only discover that by failing
and pushing myself out of my comfort
zone but nadia was there
and i did i remember you know back in
2004 it took a couple of weeks for me to
just de-program
this self-perception of her that she
just wasn't good at math
and that was the biggest hurdle because
once i kind of deprogrammed that
she was you know off to the races this
was a girl that a young girl at eight in
seventh grade was put into kind of a
slower math track
after about you know after that
deprogrammed that or helped deprogram it
and get it got her caught up and even
ahead of her class that within us
a year and a half she was taking
calculus so she clearly she was very
capable
and you know before this is as a
freshman in high school
she's very capable at learning math as i
think all
children and and all girls are very
capable so
i think it's a combination of you have
to have someone who truly believes it
not just giving them kind of lip service
truly believes
that not only are they capable they
should be capable
i also think it takes the time and that
kind of habit forming of let's call it
20 30 minutes a day
of seeing that if you do that practice
and that's you know khan academy is here
for that
that if you do that 20 30 minutes a day
no matter where you start within a month
two months you're going to see real
gains
and likely you would have caught up or
even surpassed where your class is
and i actually think you know i've
gotten into pedagogical debates about
whether it's good to go ahead of class
or not
but i do think for student
self-confidence if you're a seventh
grader who thought you weren't good at
math i saw it with nadia
if you can get ahead of where your class
is if you you know i remember that first
time that i learned that i taught
a nadia kind of an algebra topic and she
picked it up quite fast
you know simple solving equations and i
said you know nadia
this what i just did is in seventh grade
in fact it's not even eighth grade it's
actually a ninth grade algebra topic
and i remember still you know kind of
her i could hear it in her voice we were
actually doing it over the phone
but i can kind of hear her eyes light up
over the phone that like really
i nadia have just done ninth grade math
maybe i'm a math person so i think that
could be a fun thing is
introduce you know don't don't make
everything just about catching up
or or you know the next test start
introducing a few ideas that that are
further out you know uh with my own kids
you know
there's ideas from calculus you can
introduce the idea of a limit
you can introduce actually to very young
kids ideas of solving equations you know
i talk about this with my
uh nine-year-old daughter um and and she
gets it and when i tell her that
actually you know this is kind of a
ninth grade concept she's like oh
maybe i can understand you know maybe
maybe i'm good at this and i think i
think that's the kind of thing that
could be helpful so
yeah uh that's that's that's my best
advice but i'm definitely not not an
expert there
so um from facebook sim her
hassan says hi sal what are views on the
new policy for international students so
i think
what syme is referring to is this policy
and i only read some of the headlines or
i read some of the
articles fairly quickly but what i read
was the this notion that if a student is
not attending
a college an international student is
not attending physically attending the
campus
that they will not get a visa student
visa to attend
um i i think that's a
bad idea because it then makes the
schools
not think about what's right from a
healthcare point of view
and then they say okay i guess we're
going to have to
figure out some way for the kids to be
on campus because otherwise they're
going to have to leave
um and and so you know it's
anytime you're you're you're creating a
kind of a conflict of interest
in any space um that does not have a
clear
benefit to it i you know it's like you
know i
i don't get the benefit of of something
like
this so um yeah
that's that's my my my my my
my view on it you know when you when you
when you issue an edict that will have
um that will disrupt many people's lives
and maybe even put them in some type of
you know danger because of there's a
pandemic going around
um or even puts professors at danger not
even just the international students
puts a community in danger puts the
whole country you know
because anyone gets the the the
anyone gets coronavirus they now become
a vector to spread it to others so
that's not
a a good thing um
yeah so so that doesn't make sense and
if you're going to do something
disruptive like that it should have a
benefit and it's not clear to me what
the benefit is
of sending international students home
if they you know or not allowing them to
take um
to be here uh while taking um
while taking things distance learning if
if that's what the universities think is
most appropriate
um so so yeah i mean you can imagine
you're a software you're a sophomore at
the local university you're an
international student
uh you're on a student visa and for very
good reasons epidemiological reasons the
university has just decided
that it's best for the fall to have to
do everything online
and so you're like yeah i'll do that
i'll stay in my rented house that i'm
sharing with other friends other
students
and take that course and now all of a
sudden i'm saying
i'm hearing that i'm not allowed to do
that i will have to leave the country
which might have all sorts of
implications some of it is it's even
hard to travel right now but anyway
i'll that's my answer to that question
so from youtube adarsh persana
says is it very hard being a
not-for-profit
um on some levels yes although i think
you know to do anything in any way shape
or form at scale can be hard and there's
always going to be
competing interests you know if you're a
for-profit
you have to raise money get investors
higher up et cetera et cetera
and then the really hard thing is is you
know in some ways for-profit i think it
might be easier to raise money because
you can appeal to people's hey
i have an idea that can make you rich
you know give me a million dollars and
i'll give you 10
of my company and when this becomes a 10
billion dollar company that million will
be a billion and
people get ooh that's exciting here's
the money
the the hard part about for-profits
though is because of that motive
when you want to do something that you
think is sometimes just the right
morally thing
the right moral thing to do or it's
consistent with your values but if it's
not consistent
with what maybe some of those investors
think is should be your priority or what
they think is going to maximize their
profit
that can sometimes and you know most
most investors are i think are very good
people and they want to do the right
thing et cetera et cetera
but the mindset is look we're here to
optimize our profit we're not here to be
like
you know do-gooders so to speak now
ideally they could do both
but that's where it can it can lead to
tensions not-for-profits
kind of have the symmetric opposite
problem where everyone knows that like
the not-for-profit is very clear there's
no owners here this is our mission
we're here to do good in whatever
dimension do good is for khan academy
it's free world-class education for
anyone anywhere
um you know give access to materials
especially to students
who otherwise would not have them you
know try to move the dial and efficacy
and learning
support teachers things like that so the
good thing is
when people donate to khan academy they
know that that's what they're donating
to
you know we have a board of directors
that holds us accountable it's made up
of
many of our larger donors but also just
experts in education educators
and what i love about our board meetings
uh is that they
you know they don't they don't say i
mean we we don't have a profit in that
nation but they're saying sal how do
we need to make sure that these
philanthropic funds
are reaching the kids that need it most
we need to be able to measure efficacy
how do we engage kids who otherwise
would not be engaged that's the
conversation which i love because it's
super aligned with the mission
the hard part is is that you know you
gotta gotta raise money continuously
uh you know there are revenue streams
we've developed that are consistent with
our goals folks like the college board
pay us to do a free sat practice so that
helps
um we have corporate sponsors but for
the most part you know as you saw at the
beginning of this i i ask a lot of
people for money all the time and you
know
you got to kind of check your ego at the
door when you're asking for money
from people um but you know there's
positives to that too i think when
people donate it brings them into
the mission they become ambassadors for
the work uh that that you're doing and
you know one of the fears of
not-for-profit is we also obviously
don't give people stock the way you know
if you work at a google or facebook
you get a nice salary but then actually
most of your compensation comes through
stock especially if the stock is
appreciating you know you might get well
whatever your salary is you might get
two three
sometimes five 10x of that through stock
and we live you know khan academy is uh
competing in certain areas of the same
talent pool you know we have educators
and
content creators and researchers but we
also hire a lot of engineers designers
and product managers and we could
directly compete
uh with the googles and facebooks of the
world and there was a fear that we would
not be able to attract the same talent
because we can't give stock because
there is no such thing as stock and khan
academy
um the good thing is we have been able
to track talent which
shows you that you know really great
people if you pay them enough you know
so they can
live and send their kids to school in
college and go on vacations you need a
restaurant every now and then
that they actually care more about
mission intellectually challenging work
and being able to work with other really
impressive mission aligned people so
we're seeing that
so anyway you could have i i i would i
believe any anyone running an
organization that's a not-for-profit or
for-profit at the scale of a khan
academy with the reach of a khan academy
uh you know wouldn't feel relaxed all
the time
uh but to your quit point you know
there's definitely struggles of a
not-for-profit you know my dream is that
khan academy is an institution that
lasts forever that when
maybe one day there's an endowment so
that it can last for hundreds of years
you know for and billions of people
because i think the social return on
investment is definitely there
um so you know fingers fingers crossed
so from facebook man time goes by fast
every time i do this i didn't realize
that
only a few minutes left but i go a
little bit longer there's a lot of
really good questions here
from facebook robert hagen or hagen says
do you recommend daily lessons during
summer break while i want my son to
enjoy his summer break i also know
options for summer fun are limited due
to social distancing
so my view and you know i've i'm a
self-described
tiger cousin for my family that's how
khan academy started
and i have three kids now i would say
yes
and this doesn't mean ruining your son's
summer vacation
it means 30 minutes a day of math
maybe 30 minutes a day of reading and
maybe 30 minutes a day of writing
journaling whatever that is and i think
if you did that and you know talk to
your son there's nothing
that's i just described an hour and a
half of a very long day where the sun
sets very late
and there's plenty of time to doing uh
for doing other things and playing
outside and all the things that we
know and love about summer so but if
they're
if if if he's able to do that not only
will his skills not atrophy
but he's likely to go into next school
year it goes back to that confidence
question whether you're a boy or a girl
just be more confident
uh have a more a bigger margin of safety
probably perceive
him or herself more as a an academic
person who's capable of learning things
so i would absolutely go for it and once
again you don't have to go forward it
doesn't have to be hours and hours a day
it can literally be
and you know worst case do half an hour
of math a day half an hour of reading
like that's not a lot so if if your son
is watching
i think if your dad asks you to do that
that is very very reasonable of him
[Laughter]
um so let's see
other we're almost out of time so i just
want to uh
does khan academy use adaptive learning
technology that's from imani malayka
to some degree we've used it and we're
trying to do more adaptive i could go i
could talk for
many a long time about that but i'll go
to the next question from youtube ramya
sivakanth do you have more than the khan
academy website well there's the website
there's the mobile app
and and also the website there's also
mobile web we also have khan academy
kids
separate from that i've mentioned a
couple of times on this forum there's a
little bit of a side project that i have
called schoolhouse.world
which is a very early stage volunteer
driven non-khan academy project but
related
where it's pairing up students who need
help
live help let's say you're on khan
academy you're learning you're getting
practice feedback you're watching videos
but you still want live help
you can go to schoolhouse.world right
now it's focused on high school
mathematics
and then there's volunteer tutors who
are running group tutoring sessions to
give folks at live health so that's
another interesting thing
that's at a very very early stage see
from facebook
jackie tate what is the best math skills
to get ready for computer science
section of khan academy well it's
interesting the computer science the
programming section of khan academy you
really don't need to know a lot of math
i would say if you get to kind of a
fifth or sixth grade level
of arithmetic uh yeah if you know your
negative numbers
you're pretty well versed with decimals
fractions
exponents i think you're pretty close to
being able to engage
on our programming it was literally
designed for elementary school kind of
late elementary school students
uh in that mind if you have kind of a
middle school level or especially even
early algebra where you're starting to
understand what a variable
is then i think you're in very very very
good shape
but a lot of ways you're doing the
programming is a great way to learn what
a variable is
for a lot of a lot of students
v x lee is asking a very flattering
question how are you so smart
um my ego is flattered by that
but i will tell you that there's many
times in life that i have and continue
to feel
not so smart so everyone feels impostor
syndrome sometimes
everyone feels out of their element
sometimes but
i've been able to probably build more
confidence than most in
in let's call it academic or
intellectual pursuits because
to the very first question i've always
been someone to ponder and try to draw
connections
and when something just doesn't make
sense i haven't been afraid to ask what
some people would call you know dumb
questions and i found that oftentimes
what you think are a dumb question when
you really dig in and double click and
ask someone
they oftentimes can be profound
questions
and that that can make you build your
your confidence so i would say
it's all about creating a habit of
learning a habit of being curious
keep asking questions don't be afraid to
to to show your vulnerability and and
fill in those gaps
because before you know it you're going
to be a you know a polymath that knows a
lot about a lot of subjects
um and you know uh let's see muhammad
sami
musaid from youtube asked someone how
can you get yourself start lighting
school liking school
look you know in most of human history
we have just never had the luxury
of investing in understanding the
universe most of human history we were
you know running away from things or
chasing down things for a meal um
or worried about wars with a neighboring
tribe or something like that and so
it's actually an incredible luxury for
us to have something and i won't i think
it's a necessity
but in compared to most of human history
it would have it would have seemed like
a luxury
to be able to have a time of your life
where you can invest and learn
and develop your critical thinking and i
know it's not always the most engaging
and sometimes it can
feel a little bit demoralizing but when
you realize that you're getting to learn
human knowledge that has been built up
over thousands of years that newton
marie curie
uh that you know the kings of of
antiquity would have
killed they probably literally would
have killed to learn the knowledge that
you get to learn
over the course of your schooling and to
realize that you know don't put it all
on
on other people to make it interesting
for you don't put it all on you know
other people to kind of spoon feed the
knowledge to you you
this is all about you really owning it
and and
and and kind of owning the hill so i'm
using a skiing analogy because i'm not a
great skier but that was that kind of
was a
unlocking for me where it's just like
don't be afraid of the hill own the hill
this is your hill
i'm still a horrible skier uh but have
that same
mindset when you're when you're learning
something don't don't put it on the
teachers like
hey teacher make this interesting for me
otherwise i'm going to check out that's
not fair to the teacher because
you say hey i'm going to put it on
myself to make it interesting and
there's more resources than ever you
have your textbooks you have your
incredible teachers
but you also have resources like khan
academy you know if you want to know why
something is useful
things like on youtube now there's
someone who's made a video about pretty
much everything on an
enrichment side of things so you know
the world's the world's your oyster you
know
it's really for you to make it what you
want to make of it so
with that i realize i'm way over time i
have a lot of fun doing these ask me any
things i think
we might be doing it again tomorrow
worst case monday
uh but either way uh i i look forward to
uh continuing our conversation so thanks
thank you everyone for joining today
you